welcome back everyone this is part five
in our series on contextual
representations we're going to focus on
Bert Bert is the slightly older sibling
to GPT but arguably just as important
and Famous
let's start with the core model
structure for Bert this is mostly going
to be combinations of familiar elements
at this point given that we've already
reviewed the Transformer architecture
invert as essentially just an
interesting use of the Transformer
as usual to illustrate I have our
sequence The Rock Rules at the bottom
here but that sequence is augmented in a
bunch of bird-specific ways so all the
way on the left here we have a class
token that's an important token for the
architecture every sequence begins with
the class token
that has a positional encoding we also
have a hierarchical positional encoding
this is given by the token sent a this
won't be so interesting for our
illustration but as I mentioned before
for problems like natural language
inference we might have a separate token
for the premise and a separate one for
the hypothesis to help encode the fact
that a word appearing in the premise is
a slightly different occurrence of that
word than when it appears in a
hypothesis and that generalizes to lots
of different kinds of hierarchical
position for different tasks that we
might pose
but we have this very position sensitive
encoding of our input sequence
we look up the embedding representations
for all those pieces as usual and then
we do an additive combination of them to
get our first context sensitive encoding
of this input sequence in these vectors
that are in green here
and then just as with GPT we have lots
of Transformer blocks potentially dozens
of them repeated until we finally get to
some output states which I've given in
dark green here and those are going to
be kind of the basis for further things
that we do with the model
that's the structure let's think about
how we train this artifact the core
objective is masked language modeling or
MLM and the idea here is essentially
that we're going to mask out or obscure
the identities of some words in the
sequence and then have the model try to
reconstruct the missing piece
so for our sequence we could have a
scenario where we have no masking on the
word rules but we nonetheless train the
model to predict rules at that time step
that might be relatively easy as a
reconstruction task
harder we'll be doing masking so in this
case we have a special designated token
that we insert in the place of the token
rules and then we try to get the model
to a state where it can reconstruct that
rules was the missing piece using the
full bi-directional context around that
point
and then relatedly in addition to
masking we could do random word
replacement so in this case we simply
take the actual word in this case rules
and replace it with a random one like
every and then try to have the model
learn to predict what was the actual
token at that position and all of these
things are using the bi-directional
context of the model in order to do this
reconstruction task
when we train this model we mask out
only a small percentage of all the
tokens mostly leaving the other ones in
place so that the model has lots of
context to use to predict the masked or
missing or corrupted tokens that's
actually a limitation of the model and
inefficiency and the MLM objective that
Elektra in particular will seek to
address
here's the MLM loss function in some
detail again as before with these loss
functions there are a lot of details
here but I think the crucial thing to
zoom in on is first the numerator it's
very familiar from before we're going to
use the embedding representation of the
token that we want to predict and we're
going to get a DOT product of that with
a model representation in this case we
can use the entire surrounding context
leaving out only the representation at T
whereas for the auto regressive
objective that we reviewed before we
could only use the preceding context to
make this prediction
the other thing to notice here is that
we have this indicator function Mt here
which is going to be one if we're
looking at a mass token and zero
otherwise and so what that's essentially
doing is turning off this objective for
tokens that we didn't mask out so we get
a learning signal only from the mass
tokens or the ones that we have
corrupted
and that again feeds into a kind of
inefficiency inefficiency of the
subjective because we in effect do the
work of making predictions for all the
time steps but get an error signal for
the loss function only for the ones that
we have designated as masked in some
sense
for the Burt paper they supplemented the
MLM objective with a binary next
sentence prediction task so in this case
we use our Corpus resources to create
actual sentence sequences with all of
their special tokens in them and for
sequences that actually occurred in the
Corpus we label them is next and then
for negative instances we have randomly
chosen sentences that we pair up and
label them as not next the motivation
for this part of the objective is to
help the model learn some discourse
level information as part of learning
how to reconstruct sequences and I think
that's a really interesting intuition
about how we might bring in even richer
Notions of context into the Transformer
representations
when we think about transfer learning or
fine-tuning there are a few different
approaches that we can take here's a
depiction of the Transformer
architecture and the standard
lightweight thing to do is to build out
task parameters on top of the final
output representation above the class
token I think that works really well
because the class token is used as the
first token in every single sequence
that Bert processes and it's always in
that fixed position so it becomes a kind
of constant element that contains a lot
of information about the corresponding
sequence so the standard thing is to
build like a few dense layers on top of
that and then maybe do some
classification learning there but of
course as with GPT we shouldn't feel
limited by that and a standard
alternative to this would be to pull
together all of the output States and
then build the task parameters on top of
that kind of mean pooling or Max pooling
or whatever decision you use to just to
bring together all of the output states
to make predictions for your task and
that can be very powerful as well
because you bring in much more
information about the entire sequence
I thought I would remind you a little
bit about how tokenization Works
remember that Bert has this tiny
vocabulary and therefore a tiny static
embedding space and the reason it gets
away with that is because it does
wordpiece tokenization which means we
have lots of these word pieces indicated
by these double hash marks here and that
means that the model essentially never
uncs out any of its input tokens but
rather breaks them down into familiar
pieces and then the intuition is that
the power of masked language modeling in
particular will allow us to learn
internal representations of things that
correspond even to words like encode
which got spread out over multiple
tokens
let's talk a little bit about core model
releases
for the original Bert paper I believe
they just did Bert base and Bert large
encased and uncased variance I would
recommend always using the cased ones at
this point very happily lots of teams
including the Google team have worked to
develop even smaller ones so we have
tiny mini small and medium as well
uh and this is really welcome because it
means you can do a lot of development on
these tiny models and then possibly
scale up to larger ones so for example
Bert tiny has just two layers that is
two Transformer blocks relatively small
model dimensionality and relatively
small expansion inside its feed forward
layer for a total number of parameters
of only four million I will say that
that is tiny but it's surprising how
much juice you can get out of it when
you fine-tune it for tasks
but then you can move on up to many
small medium and then large is the
largest from the original release at 24
layers relatively large model
dimensionality relatively large feed
forward layer for a total number of
parameters of around 340 million
all of these models because all of them
as far as I know use absolute positional
embeddings have a maximum sequence
length of 512 and that's an important
limitation that increasingly we're
feeling is constraining the kinds of
work we can do with models like Bert
there are many new releases and I would
say to stay up to date you could check
out hugging face which has variants of
these models for different languages and
maybe some different sizes and other
kinds of things maybe for example there
are by now versions that use relative
positional encoding which would be quite
welcome I would say
for Bert some known limitations and this
will kind of feed into subsequent things
that we want to talk about with Roberta
and Elektra especially
first the original Burt paper is
admirably detailed but it's still very
partial in terms of ablation studies and
studies of how to effectively optimize
the model and so that means that we
might not looking at the be looking at
the very best Bert that we could
possibly have if we explored more widely
Devlin at all also observe a downside
they say the first downside is that
we're creating a mismatch between
pre-training and fine-tuning since the
mask token is never seen during fine
tuning that is indeed unusual remember
the mass token is a crucial element in
training the model against the MLM
objective you introduce this foreign
element into that phase that presumably
you never see when you do fine tuning
and that could be dragging down model
performance
and the second downside that they
mentioned is one that I mentioned as
well we're using only around 15 percent
of the tokens to make predictions we do
all this work of processing these
sequences but then we turn off the
modeling objective for the tokens that
we didn't mask and we can mask only a
tiny number of them because we need the
bi-directional context to do the
Reconstruction that's kind of the
essence of the intuition there so that's
obviously any inefficient and the final
one is kind of intriguing I'll mention
this only at the end of this series this
comes from the Excel net paper and they
just observed that bird assumes the
predicted tokens are independent of each
other given the unmasked tokens which is
oversimplified as high order long range
dependency is prevalent in natural
language and this is just the
observation that if you do happen to
mask out two tokens like new and York
from the place name New York the model
will try to reconstruct those two tokens
independently of each other even though
we can see that they have a very clear
their statistical dependency The Bert
objective simply misses that and I'll
mention later on about how excelnet
brings that dependency back in possibly
to very powerful effect